so
somebody that's a really good example
somebody i think you've you've spoken
with
uh that's an intermediary that's a
powerful one it's michael malus and he's
spoken with curtis jarvin
and uh michael wrote a book about by the
way michael somewhat changed my mind
about michael malus
i'm glad he did i think i i would call
him
a friend and i think he's a underneath
it all
a really kind human being and i think
your skepticism about him was initially
from a surface level of what did you
call them hyenas
the trolls and so on i'm not happy about
his
it's been so long since i've seen good
trolls
yes so
he needs a higher quality of trolling
but he aspires to that
i mean it you know disagree or not
i really enjoy how much care
he puts into the work he does like on
north korea and
study of the world and how much
privately
but also in public love he has for
people
especially those who are powerless yeah
just a genuine
admiration for them uh for but yeah
i think curtis actually does too i don't
know
i mean you have to appreciate the first
time i met curtis he introduced to me
says
i'm the most right-wing person you've
ever met i was just like
well this is a conversation that's
already over it's
theatrical in a way that's not conducted
to actually having a real
well it just turned me so it turned me
off because it was like
you need to be the most right-wing
person and so it's like i'm a troll i'm
a troll
yeah okay why are we doing this yeah but
what i'm trying to get is different
i'm trying to say that michael malus is
a friend of yours if you found out
something terrible
you should be a friend you should still
continue to be his friend
and you know and michael's case is very
likely that we'll find
out something curtis is an acquaintance
of mine because he hangs around with
some people that i know
i did not get it i've started to
understand why the people in my life
some of them are curtis yarvin fans many
of them disregard the stupid stuff
but my feeling is is that too much
poison organ not enough fish i don't
know how to serve that too intermingled
i'm not your chef
you